up on 5 57 on your monday morning so  this week on the big squeeze doesn't  look too bad the 95 515 gonna be down to  one maybe two lanes this is going on on  the big squeeze but it is further south  there between boulder highway and  flamingo from nine o'clock each night  until five each following morning  there's also work going on on desert inn  under the freeway this week but both di  and eastern are going to be closed to  through traffic next week under the  freeway eastern and d.i for bridge  demolition and reconstruction and  there's a ton more work yet to go on  what's officially called the i-515  rehabilitation project so we have a link  to ndot's website about the project on  our web page 8newsnow.com you click  traffic then driving you crazy buckle up  drive carefully and please put down that  phone something's driving you crazy you  can always email me traffic eight at  eight news now dot com